Muhammad Salah, Darwin Nunes, and their
teammates took a step away from the
usual high-intensity drills and match
preparations. Finding themselves
immersed in the tranquil embrace of the
eco in temple, players swapped their
training kits for traditional robes. And
far from Anfield, Liverpool found
something deeper than tactics or
fitness. The action is in itself kufur.
You went to a temple. It's that me going
to a church and doing the cross. The
action is kufur. It is kufur. Does it
make you a kafir?
Alam alaikum guys. Before the video
starts, brother and sisters, one um is
working in Pakistan with the floods
that's hit the country. 1,700 people
have lost their life. Millions of people
have lost their homes and been
displaced. So the videos that you can
see here, the pictures that you can see
guys, is demonstrating what one um is
doing on the ground. We know Gaza is
important and we know what's going on
there. But brothers and sisters, we
cannot enable and turn a blind eye to
the suffering of Muslims in different
countries. Be it Pakistan, be it Turkey,
the earthquakes, wherever it may be,
Afghanistan, so many other places need
our help. And I know all of us have
given as much as we can to Gaza. But
brothers and sisters, wahi, just imagine
your home wrecked. Thousands of people
have died. Your family members have
passed away. You have nowhere to live.
Brothers and sisters, they need our help
as much as Gaza does. So I urge you
guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. Donate whatever amount, even if
it's£1. The prophet peace be upon him
said the best form of saddaka is to give
water. Brothers and sisters, let's give
them food and shelter and water to drink
so they can overcome this tragedy.
Inshallah, I urge you guys to go to the
link and donate now. Enjoy the video
to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well
inshallah. Has Muhammad Salah left
Islam? Well, we're going to be watching
videos inshallah. And obviously, we are
in no position to declare that, but
we're going to watch some disturbing
stuff and understand him visiting this
monk, this Buddhist uh temple. What does
it mean? What are the beliefs of the
Buddhist? Is it religious? Is it just
something a practice that you do yoga?
It's just actions or is it more than
that inshallah? So, here's a video we're
going to watch of him in the temple. And
then we're going to go to where this all
stems from. We're going to know learn a
bit more about Buddhism and the
connections to Hinduism and where it all
started in India. And we're going to go
to um Hindus who believe this and hear
it from their own mouth. Is this just
something that you do physically or is
there something a deeper spiritual
connection which is shik? Let's watch
out for ourel inshallah.
>> Under the calming serenity of Tokyo's
spiritual heart, the Liverpool squad
experienced a unique and unforgettable
moment today. Muhammad Salah, Darwin
Nunees, and their teammates took a step
away from the usual highintensity drills
and match preparations, finding
themselves immersed in the tranquil
embrace of the Ecoin Temple, one of the
most sacred Zen temples in Japan.
As the squad arrived in the early
morning light, there was a noticeable
shift in energy. Players swapped their
training kits for traditional robes and
entered the temple's serene courtyard in
silence. Guided by resident monks, they
were introduced to the ancient practice
of Zazin, a seated meditation technique
designed to bring clarity, calmness, and
awareness.
Muhammad Salah appeared particularly
connected to the moment, closing his
eyes with deep focus and steady breath.
The Egyptian forward, known for his
spiritual discipline and composure on
the pitch, embraced the practice with a
sense of reverence. Darwin Nunees,
usually full of energy and fire, visibly
softened during the session, breathing
slowly and occasionally exchanging
peaceful glances with his teammates.
Around them, the likes of Virgil van
Djk, Dominic Soasli, and Trent Alexander
Arnold sat cross-legged in silent
contemplation.
Arn Slott, the new head coach, observed
with a warm smile, clearly valuing the
opportunity for his players to bond and
recharge mentally. It was a moment of
collective stillness, a stark contrast
to the roaring stadiums, and
adrenalinefueled challenges of the
Premier League. The sounds of nature,
gentle wind rustling bamboo leaves, and
the distant chirping of birds created a
meditative backdrop. At the end of the
session, a dong echoed across the
courtyard, marking the conclusion of
their spiritual journey. As the players
slowly opened their eyes, many were
smiling, not just at the experience, but
at the rare peace it brought to their
minds and spirits. In Tokyo, far from
Anfield, Liverpool found something
deeper than tactics or fitness. A shared
moment of inner reflection, bonding, and
balance ahead of the demanding season
ahead. Okay. So in we're going to watch
some more other videos but let's just
break this down inshallah. So this is
very interesting because in the Quran
Allah subhana says inah
that um sorry um in chapter 5 verse 51.
Yep. Oh believers take neither the Jews
or the Christians as guardians. They are
guardians of each other. Whoever does
will be counted as one of them. Surely
Allah does not guide the wrongdoing
people. So here we are told not to take
them as intimate friends as you know
close close friends. Yes. So subhan
Allah or they are one of them. I hope
you guys enjoy the video guys. But
before that, please download the Salah
Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we are a
charity. All of our services on the app
is for free. Free kiblinder, no ads,
free salah reminders, encourages to
pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah, salah hubs, and
many, many more brother sisters. We are
not an app that shares your information
with third parties. All of our services
on the app is for free. Download it now
inshallah and enjoy it, guys. Let's go
back to the video now. There's also
another hadith um by the prophetam who
says whoever it is Ibar reported that
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said whoever
imitates people is one of them. And this
is exactly what we see with Mosah when
it comes to Christmases in 2023 2024 if
I'm not mistaken celebrating Christmas
the effort that he goes into the tree he
has a whole thing ready to take a
picture from the pajamas to the socks to
the you name it the background. But the
same guy when his E, he takes a picture
like he's in his pajama just woke up. Uh
yeah. Okay. You can see he has an
inferiority complex. He himself has an
inferiority complex. And him being the
leader of the house, his children and
his family follow. And that's why you on
your you are going to be questioned. Now
this is what happened guys. It leads to
what? It leads down. Look lookan does
never come to you Mo Salah and say go
and commit shik. It's lookan's not
stupid. He's not going to come and say
go and commit zena. He's going to slowly
slowly just a friend. his this so much
so subhan Allah you are a role model you
should not be taken as a role model at
all for that uh let me make it you have
an inferiority complex okay so it is
very clear and there are videos which
we're going to look into in go into
Buddhism you have an inferiority complex
for you to put all of that effort in to
Christmas and wake up and do a little
post or a thing for nothing for eat
where's your eat celebrations where's
your decorations for your kids and
family where nothing so what is Buddhism
let's go into this in because people
think and we're going to go to mushik
these mushri who
testify and say there's a connection to
Hinduism with this. Okay. Buddhism is
both a religion and a philosophical
tradition that began in in India about
2,500 years ago with the teachings of
Sedartha Gaut Gautama known as the
Buddha, the awakened one. Core idea
Buddhism is about understanding the
nature of suffering and finding path to
freedom, enlightenment or nirvana. The
Buddha taught that suffering duka arises
from craving and ignorance. But it can
overcome through wisdom, ethical living
and meditation. The four noble truths.
There are foundations of Buddhism like
involves suffering. Suffering has uh
causes mainly craving, attachment and
ignorance. Suffering can seize. There is
a state beyond it called nin nirvana.
the way it is a noble eight-fold path a
guide to the right living mindfulness
and wisdom Buddhist does not worship a
creator god instead it focuses on cause
and effects karma which is shik which is
shik basically cause and effect and
basically saying the cause and effect of
doing good good comes to you is
connected not to Allah they don't
believe in god is connected to you know
energy this that etc so the universe is
going to punish you etc it's basically
something an attribute that belongs to
Allah subhanaa tala as the punisher as
the one that's just is given to
something called the karma and the
possibility of liberation through
personal effort. In some schools there
are Buddhas and celestial Buddhas who
serve as guides but they're not supreme
gods. You can see the shik okay major
traditions that they have etc etc.
Buddhism today practiced by over 500
people worldwide. Some approach it is a
religion with rituals, prayers and
temples as you can see which he went to.
Yes, he went to and did the spiritual
thing. Look like some one person said
it's like somebody going to ka doing
tawah doing safar and saying h yeah I
was not in ibada I just went and just
yeah I just walked around the caba I ran
up and down no that's form of ibada yes
okay that is form of ibad okay others
see as a philosophy or psychology
mindfulness meditation self-improvement
now don't take our word for it now the
action is in itself kufur you went to a
temple it's not me going to a church and
doing the cross yes I'm doing the cross
okay and then I go there and I'm
involved in the spiritual I go and eat
of the flesh of Jesus is what it is
drink the wine even let's say it's it's
not alcohol let's say red juice you are
involved in the rituals the action is
kufur it is kufur does it make you a
kafir I cannot say that that is not my
job I am not qualified but the point is
this Allah has blessed you with so many
things and some people say like I was
reading a verse in the Quran in surah if
I'm not mistaken where Allah is saying
do you not think that when we give you
children and blessings that that Allah
is pleased with you yes wall
believe me guys it's Not that thing.
Allah gave Faron everything and he is
the most wretched that he's in hellfire
forever. Let's listen to some mushri.
Yes, Hindus who actually tell us what is
the actual belief of them. Look, listen
to it carefully for yourself. One of the
important truth you have never been told
is yoga cannot be separated from
Hinduism. Yoga is ritual.
This is
one of the important revolution
statement I making. Anybody who says
yoga is spiritual,
they are thieves
trying to steal yoga from Hinduism
and sell it, market it, package it to
the modern mind. It is not an exercise
or a process
for creating health. It is about
attaining to a dimension beyond all
dimensions.
It is about a system and a method to use
your own existing system as a ladder to
the divine to make your body to make
your mind to make your emotion and your
energies.
a ladder to the divine to make yourself
into your stepping stone towards your
ultimate nature.
>> Okay. So you can see clearly. Okay. To
that divine. Who is that divine? To
them. What is that? What what is that
divine? Who's who you trying to connect
it to? Allah. My friend, you have salah.
Yes. Your name is most salah. Yes. I
don't even know if you pray salah. I
don't know. Subhan Allah. Yes. Okay.
Subhan Allah. You've got Allah who
prescribes salah for you. Wallah. Allah
has given you so much stuff instead of
wall. Look at the infury complex man.
Instead of saying Allah has blessed me
with that. No, I'm not going to do
anything close to shik whatever it is.
You have Muslim footballers whoever when
people are you know doing the spray of
the alcohol etc. you know the champagne
they distance theirel. They work their
colleagues wait for them to go off the
pitch. They respect them. You don't even
have a backbone man. Wallah shame on
you. You don't even your name is Mo.
Your name is Muhammad. You don't even
call yourself Muhammad. Yes. Subhan
Allah. You are ashamed to subhan Allah
come and say actually no I'm not going
to take part of this this against my
religion you know why you are more
concerned about what the creation says
and Allah will humiliate you at the cost
of that creation not only in this life
but in the hereafter I don't want to
long this video out in a nutshell you
guys have understood it's very clear may
Allah and you can see from Christmas
trees as you can see as it's where is
slowly going that's what said the one
who imitates the disbelievers he is one
of them and guess what you are going to
become one of them at this rate the way
you're
Okay, you are and you might think
unintentionally let let me tell you
something. It's at the end of the day,
what is it in the sight of Allahh? If it
takes you at the f of Islam, my friend,
you might think, oh, it's nothing
harmful. No one, you don't decide what
is allowed or not based on your
subjective feelings or emotions. That's
all I have to say in brother and
sisters, may Allah protect us. Wallah,
you can see anything that keeps us away
from Allah is a curse. I don't care what
money he has, how much he earns. Let me
say something. Anything that makes my
kids go away from is a disaster. It's
catastrophe. It's chaos. And anything
that we deem a calamity that brings me
is a blessing for Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. Most may Allah subhanaa tala
guide you uh and allow you to have a
backbone for your religion. Inshallah
you've got salah. You don't need no
whatever he was doing there. Subhan
Allah. May Allah guide you and guide us.
Till next time.